Clients and servers can be most
simply understood as computers
communicating across the Internet.
We define the client as the computer
that wants information, and the server
as the computer that has information
that can be shared with clients.
This means that a client has to initiate
communication to request information,
while the server constantly stays
listening for any clients to communicate
with it, and responds with the data
that the client requested.
Let's briefly discuss some of the
important concepts in order to better
understand how this actually happens.
So we know that clients and servers
can communicate with each other, but
how do we know that they're all
speaking the same language?
Well, protocols are like the grammatical
rules that we use to make sure all
machines on the Internet
are communicating in the same way.
There are several protocols that
computers on the Internet adhere to.
The most common three
are the Transmission Protocol, or TCP,
the Internet Protocol, IP, and
the HyperText Transfer Protocol or HTTP.
The Transmission Control Protocol or
TCP enables information
to be broken into small packets and
sent between clients and servers.
If a packet is lost somewhere along the
way the sender and receiver have a way
of figuring out which of the packets is
missing and request that they be resent.
The counterpart to TCP is UDP, User
Datagram Protocol, which is good for
streaming content like music or video.
Similar to postal addresses, IP
addresses allow messages to be properly
routed to all participants
on the Internet.
For simplicity's sake, we can assume
that every device on the Internet gets
an IP address that is
either statically or
dynamically assigned by
the Internet service provider.
Here's the IP address of my laptop,
and here is the IP address for Google.
When I type google.com into my browser,
my computer first figures out the IP
address of Google by looking it up
in a Domain Name Server, or DNS.
Think of DNS as a big online phonebook
that finds theIP address of web URLs.
Once DNS gives my computer the IP
address, it uses that address to
initiate communication with
the server for Google.
Since multiple applications using
the Internet can run on one machine,
operating systems use ports to
designate channels of communication
on the same IP address.
Placing a colon after an IP address,
with another number indicates that we
want to communicate on a specific port
on the device using that IP address.
On most machines,
port numbers can range from 0 to 65,536.
The first 10,000 ports are often times
reserved by the operating system for
a specific use.
Port 80 is the most common port for
web servers.
So most websites we use every day
are hitting port 80 when they
reach a server.
8080 is also a common port for
web communications.
When client and server applications
are on the same machine
we indicate this with
the term localhost.
Localhost also has a special
IP address of 127.0.0.1.
Whenever we type localhost, or this
special IP address into a browser or
web application,
the operating system knows to look for
this resource locally and
not go out to the Internet.